[Music]
all right mate you're ready how do you
decide who sits where on the team coach
uh well when we joined the team
it was already given to us our seats
so i have to put left now i'm bennett
from right
and that's my seat now so now we can sit
on it i just get told i'm gonna sit and
run it's next to tom so there you go
who's the biggest character in the team
you or
me
wrong answer yes correct answer i'll
stop with him in all the camps you mean
stayed with
that's what i meant you have to speak
english for the audience what's your
favorite sas product and
what's your favorite flavour
tiramisu
bake that's good
that's the correct answer
who's the best teammate in training you
also you because i beat you every
time what it's true well it makes me
good because you can beat me yeah it's
morale
any superstitions yeah not really i
don't really believe in that to be
honest i touched my helmet three times
actually when i think when i get out of
here when we almost don't crash in the
race so i missed the crash yeah and i go
bye-bye
yeah do you yeah
if you had one superpower what would it
be
to be able to fly off to town trouble
why
right because
dope mate
next question who's got the worst
fashion sense
um
yeah that's
a good look mate hater looks a mess
sometimes yeah he rolls out of bed
no don't you ethan
who is the team dj
you're inexperienced but you've got some
good tunes so ben is a team dj it just
means time time to develop in his role
tell us about the ineos grenadiers chess
club who's the current master of chess
[Music]
why swifty no luke cause luke beats 50.
no
only the first time
all right so he's 50
50's unbeaten the past
five days more magnus isn't very good
because he's he's never won yeah and
i've only played three games but i won
against tom
about an hour ago
that was just because he's not very good
so i wasn't paying attention
what's your advice for anyone looking to
get into racing
you have to
enjoy it if you don't enjoy it you're
not gonna be very good
because you
yeah you better anything you enjoy
what's the most important thing you've
learned from me
i have learned from you
to be more calm
tom's really relaxed and i wasn't as
relaxed and then i've become in the
middle
and to become better at racing and not
training
i'd say ben's
pretty professional
he does his homework and
things like that goes to bed on time
yeah boring you just said that so thank
you
ryder you least like to race against and
why does it i don't really have a right
at least like the race against
my answer is tom because he always beats
me and i've beaten him four times thank
you is that finalized now yes
last question
what does it mean to be an ineos
grenadier
oh big question um
[Music]
i'm quite proud to be in the australia
actually so um
yeah just happy that i'm in the team and
with everyone
um i think it's a big team and it was a
dream to be here and now i'm here and
yeah i don't really know what else i can
say about that i think it's quite
special really what a serious question
yeah are you serious well then
congratulations thank you
[Music]